Je suis venu au Chili il y a environ quatre
mois et c'est devenu mon pays mais
ce dont nous avons besoin dans ce pays, c'est de la
solidarité dans les cinémas hé ma caméra viens
avec la mienne maintenant
merci tow
bonjour
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu un coup d'État militaire
nous devons y aller allons-nous  allez je ne sais pas
juste
vous savez où il est
c'est un endroit dans le sud complètement
coupé du monde extérieur qu'est-ce que ça
s'appelle Colonia Dignidad c'est une sorte de
culte autour d'un homme qui s'appelle Paul
Schaffer pour mettre en place un monde selon
son  règles au milieu de nulle part et
si j'y allais rejoint je ferai que
je ne reviendrai peut-être jamais dans les heures
c'est une vie humble de porno une fois que vous nous rejoignez
mr.  moi c'est que comment tu sers le seigneur
tu dois avoir un petit ami quelqu'un qui l'
aime Non
et pour gagner comme une fille je t'assure de
faire face
oh tu penses que tu as fait une erreur que tu
n'aurais pas dû venir